（こちらは有名なコカ・コーラの会社です）
（コーラはYouTuberの間でも大人気ですよね）
（メントスとの相性がバッチリだそうですよ）
↑
コーラに何かと縁がある男
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
今、僕は！
コカコーラの！
本社にいま～す！
緊張しております･･･
えーと僕Twitterやってるんですけども
Twitterのアカウントのフォロワーさんが
なんと！
390万人！
います！
実はなんやかんや･･･
日本5位でございます！
【Twiterフォロワー数TOP5】
１位「〇吉弘行 」
２位「松本〇志」
３位「〇ゃりーぱみゅぱみゅ」
４位「R〇LA」
５位「もやし」
日本5位でございます！
僕、Twitterの影響力が
実はありそうなんで！
今回ちょっとその影響力がどれぐらいなのかの
検証をしてみたいと
思います
で今回は僕のTwitterの影響力を検証するために
コカ・コーラさんの
というアプリをちょっと
利用してみようと
思います！
で、Coke ONっ･･･というアプリ･･･
前にヒカキンさんとちょっと説明したと
思うんですけども
Coke ON対応の自販機で
１本ドリンクを買うと
スタンプが１個貰えます
で、15個たまると
好きなドリンク１本と
タダで！
交換できます！
なんで簡単な話
ドリンクを15本購入すると
その時点でもう
１本タダで
貰えるという
Coke ONというアプリがあるんですけども
で今回ですね
期間限定で
というキャンペーンをやっておりまして
誰かからCoke ONのアプリを紹介してもらいます
そうすると
紹介された人に
スタンプが
14個
その瞬間溜まります
何か好きなドリンク１個買ってください
そうすると
１本無料で！
手に入ります
めちゃくちゃお得です今
さらに
紹介した僕にも
なんと見返りがありまして
僕が紹介した友達が購入すると
僕にもスタンプが5個
入ります
３人やった時点で僕はもう
ドリンク１本手に入るという
もうWin-Winの関係を築けるわけでございます
というわけで
フォロワー390万人の力･･･
見せてやるよおおお！！
ではツイート文を考えていきましょう
いかに僕が
フォロワーの皆さんに
Coke ONのアプリインストールしてほしい！
それでついでに
ドリンク買って欲しい！って思わせるかが
大事なポイントなのでちょっと
文章ちゃんと考えましょう
「本気」っていう言葉･･･ですね
結構本気で僕やってるんで
で「！」マーク使うとちょっと、ふざけてそうなんで
「。」を使います
で、ちゃんと画像をつけてつぶやきます
一応
お願いしたそうな
瞑らな瞳をしてみました
だから･･･
何人がCoke ONの自販機に
走りに行ってくれるのか･･･！
４･･･
３･･･
２･･･
１、つぶやきまぁす！
はい
今つぶやきました
果たしてここから１時間後
僕は
スタンプを何個ゲットできるのか･･･
そして
何本のコカ・コーラを買えるのか･･･
楽しみです
○
〇
（前回買ったあのうまい棒どうしよう･･･）
わっ！わっ！わっ！
わっ！わっ！
もう来ましたもう来ました！
いきなり誰かがもう買ってくれたみたいです！
「友達紹介ボーナス」
「スタンプ５個ゲット！」･･･
ありがとうございあす！！
こういう感じで溜まってくんですねおそらく
はい、というわけで10分経ちました
ちょっと１･･･回
様子を見てみましょう
うおっ、うおっびっくりした！
「友達紹介ボーナス」
スタンプが170個！
来ております
170個って何人だ？
10分で35人の方が
インストールして
かつ、自販機まで行って
ドリンクを買ってくださっております
ありがとうございまあす！！
え、結構･･･
普通に嬉しいですｗ
※早送り
※豆知識
コーラのレシピは企業秘密らしいよ
はい、というわけで･･･えー
企画開始から30分経ちました
さらにあれからスタンプは何個来ているのでしょうか
ううわああこれマジでやばい！！
すごっ！
スタンプさらに
1240個追加でーす
ありがとうございまーす！！
やばい俺
億万長者も
夢じゃないねえ！！
はい、でちょっと
あと30分あるんですけども
ここからちょっとあんまりアプリ見ないようにして
ちょっと最後の結果を
待とうと思います
はい
というわけで
１時間経って
わたくしは
何個のスタンプを
手に入れることが
できたのでしょうか
１時間でどれだけ
スタンプ貰えたか
全く想像がつきません
ではそちらに、ちょっと
コカ・コーラさんからの公式の
データがありますので
見ます
はい！
･･･
マジですかｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗ
すごっ！
えー１時間で･･･
６０５５個のスタンプをいただきました！
ありがとうございまあす！！
いや本当にこればかりはもう･･･
Twitterの皆さんが
協力してくれたおかげで
溜まったので
良かったです･･･
あの、協力してくださった皆さんも
ドリンク･･･2本買えた！
ってすごい喜んでくださる方が多かったので
あのすごい･･･
見てて僕も嬉しかったです
ドリンクで計算すると
403本分！
スタンプ･･･
いただきました･･･
ありがとうございますｗｗｗ
１年に一本買っても
結構余るくらいの
数です･･･ｗ
億万長者やあ！
人数で言うと
1211名の方が！
えー、僕のTwitterを見て
Coke ONをインストールして
１時間のうちに
Coke ONの自販機まで足を運んで
ドリンクを買ってくださいました
ありがとうございまあす！！
嬉しいですね･･･ｗ
では実際にチケットとドリンクを
交換しに行ってきましょう！
403ぼおおん！！
※謎の口パク
※そしてこの顔である
はい
というわけでドリンクチケットを使って
ドリンクと引き換えてきたんですけども
足りなくて･･･
全部出来ませんでしたあああ！！
残りのチケットは
のんびりと
使わさせていただきます！
はい！というわけで
Coke ONのアプリを持っていない人
今ダウンロードしたらすごくお得なので！
ダウンロードURLは動画の概要欄にあります！
是非そちらからダウンロードしてみてください！
じゃあ
いただきます！
うめえぇぇぇ！
全部飲めねえや
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　もぉ↓や↓し↓　も↓や↑も↓やぁ↑しぃ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬